hello everybody I had a rough week I
went to a bar recently a fella thought I
was looking at his girlfriend he said if
well if you do that again I'm gonna I'm
gonna tear you a new [ __ ] and there's
no right answer so I just said well good
then I'll have to [ __ ] and I ran as
fast as I could and people will tell you
you can't run from your problems that's
not entirely true though if your problem
is location-based try moving to a
different location I worry about crime a
lot I sleep with a bad under my bed in
case my apartment has ever burgled that
way the robber will get a complimentary
bed after he shoots me in the head with
his gun if I come out with a bat he has
a gun all I can do at that point to say
don't shoot it's illegal I hope he
respects that instead of carrying mace I
carry Axe body spray it's cheaper it's
more effective a guy tried to mug me and
I sprayed him he said you what is that
I said dart temptation
he said good lord it's the worst thing
I've ever smelled and I said exactly now
people are gonna think you're a
douchebag I think the reason I worry so
much about crime is that I watch too
many crime programs on television never
watch a documentary about serial killers
and think to yourself other than the
murdering I have a lot in common with
this guy he's a misunderstood genius
then the narrator save did a lot of
weird stuff and he was by himself at
home and I'm not gonna cast the first
stone on that one after all I just
watched five documentaries in a row on
serial killers and now I gotta eat some
of you thought that was inappropriate
that's okay I'm used to it a lot of
people think I have Asperger's and I
know that because they tell me they
think I have Asperger's a friend said
Joe it seems like you have Asperger's if
you have no idea what's appropriate to
say to other adults I said Allie that's
true I know you're not supposed to tell
other adults I think you have Asperger's
but maybe he has Asperger's and that's
why he said that
I do plort out whatever I think is best
once a friend said joy be married 25
years now if only I hadn't gotten
divorced I said of course I'd be a great
surfer if I could stand up on the board
and do any of that but you're right if
facts were different other facts
relating to the initial facts would also
be different if things aren't what they
were they would not be what they are you
win that argument every time it's the
worst one I have to call a lady on the
phone asking for a date sometimes I get
so nervous I can't remember any of my
words so I make a date script but
sometimes lady I was talking to would
say something I hadn't accounted for my
pre-planned dialogue ruining everything
I'm like hi I'm Jo how are you
she's like I'm good how are you I'm like
[ __ ] I don't everything for that it is
just getting harder and harder to be a
human I noticed people are getting more
and more judgmental I saw an actor
apologize for something on the news of
my friend blurred out
he only apologized because he got caught
and I said well yeah that's how
apologies have always works
if you apologize before you get caught
that's a confession learn your words I
do think it's getting easier to be
youngster everytime I hear the phrase
sticks and stones may break your bones
but names will never hurt you I think it
was a lot harder to be a kid when that
was coined not only are we getting hit
with sticks and stones but you're
getting made fun of so much it made
sense to compare those to quite
unrelated experiences how was school
today not good they called me a loser
but all things being equal it was a lot
better than that time they hit me with
all the stones that's literally how they
murdered hookers in the Bible tape it
down a notch guys 412 thanks so much
everyone
you